you
hello everyone we are pleased to have
you join us for the second annual
cardinal health lab exchange welcome to
today's live broadcast DC healthcare
update for laboratory ins and Judy or
aqua blab roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's event today's
webcast is presented by lab routes comm
the leading social media site for
science professionals and sponsored by
Cardinal Health cardinal health improves
the cost effectiveness of healthcare we
helped pharmacies hospitals and
ambulatory surgery centers clinical
laboratories and physician offices focus
on patient care while reducing costs
enhancing efficiency and improving
quality we operate the nation's largest
network or radio pharmacies and with
nearly 100 years of experience Cardinal
Health provides medical products and
services to many of America's most
prestigious medical institutions in fact
most US hospitals use our products and
services to provide care for their
patients cardinal health continues to
revolve applying vast resources
knowledge and healthcare expertise that
allows us to create value in a dynamic
evolving industry this understanding of
what's next empowers us to make a
difference for customers patients
manufacturers and healthcare partners
across the continuum of care before we
start there are a few instructions this
is an educational webinar and thus
offers free continuing education credits
after the webinar is over and to get
your credit click on the button located
in the bottom left hand corner of your
web page we want to hear from you during
this interactive broadcast so please ask
questions or leave us a comment the
answers are welcome to you can do this
by hitting them green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window in
typing in your comments and questions
we'll try to get to as many as we can
and we'll follow up if you don't have
time today want a better look you can
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you can't
hear or see this presentation properly
let us know by clicking on the support
button on the top right or use the Q&A
button we'll make sure we try to resolve
any issues now let's get right to
today's presenter we are proud to
welcome Michael BB partner and senior
vice president at ads
Michael BB advises clients on all
aspects of reimbursement and strategic
policy planning including specific
quoting strategies in the physician
office hospital and other sites of
service mr. Beebe also works with
clients on the evidence requirements
needed to secure reimbursement and
approaches to obtaining the desired
levels of payment for the physician the
facility or the laboratory test prior to
joining ed he was at the American
Medical Association for 14 years his
most recent position was director of CPT
it was a central participant in AMA
advocacy efforts involving public and
private coverage coding and
reimbursement issues including provider
class action litigation CMS position
payment negotiations and local coverage
determinations mr. bewbies complete bio
is found on the labyrinth website I will
now turn the presentation over to
Michael BB thank you very much pleased
to be talking today about DC healthcare
update I'm going to be running through
several of the activities going on in
Washington DC policy regulation statutes
that have occurred over the past year to
bring everyone up to speed there's going
to be a fairly general presentation
because a lot going on but I will get
into some specifics when we I started to
talk about the pama regulations that
came out a couple months ago and then
also about the Macra the Medicare
changes to Medicare physician payment
for for physicians so let's get started
here going to the next slide overview
and then the following slide which is DC
activities in the past year which is
entitled that slide and I should
probably apologize right off the bat my
some internet issues so I'm going to be
they're going to be moving my slides for
me do it the old-fashioned way so again
i'm talking about past impossible
legislation and then also some old new
expected regulations
so in the past legislation be talking
about the Medicare device tax suspension
for two years and then under possible a
legislative changes talk a little bit
about 21st century cures the
congressional interest in action around
FDA regulation of LD TS and then under
old and new expected regulations talk
about you know the the existing regs for
the Medicare physician fee schedule the
outpatient prospective payment system
and ambulatory surgery centers the
clinical lab fee schedule in the
inpatient prospective payment system
regulations and then the new or expected
new regulations what just came out from
macro is a proposed rule to implement
the macro regs the changes to physician
payment the pama proposed rule the final
rule as many has no has been delayed and
that's much anticipated and then talk
about ldt guidance and how final
guidance has been delayed a little bit
and obviously connect that back to what
might be going on in Congress there so
go on to the next slide we're going to
talk about past and possible legislation
the first topic here slide number five
is the medical device tax suspension
just as an overview on the medical
device tax slide 6 the tax itself is
expected to raise approximately 30
billion dollars over the course of ten
years it's a two point three percent
medical device excise tax it's in effect
for sales after December 31st 2012 it
was included as part of the Affordable
Care Act it was intended as an offset to
help pay for the Affordable Care Act the
US Treasury audit found that the tax in
the first half of 2013 raised
approximately nine hundred and thirteen
million dollars it's not a very popular
tax
and there's been several attempts to
repeal the tax including votes to repeal
the entire Affordable Care Act in the
house several house bill bills to repeal
the device tax and a bipartisan
non-binding repeal of the tax in the
Senate so recently the consolidated
appropriations tax appropriations act of
2016 and a company tax extenders package
suspended the two-point-three percent
medical device tax for two years
beginning january 1st 2016 through
december 31st 2017 this two-year
moratorium is expected to cost less than
four billion dollars but unless further
action is taken the tax will become
effective again after December 31st 2017
so basically in 2018 it will pick up
again 21st century cures this has been
around for the last couple years the the
intention of 21st century cures is to is
to develop and accelerate the discovery
delivery of life-saving life-improving
therapies and transform the quest for
faster cures in the health care system
so broadly the 21st century cures plans
to achieve these aims by removing
barriers to increase research
collaboration corporate patient
perspective into the drug development
and regulatory review process measure
success and identifying diseases earlier
through personalized medicine genomics
modernized clinical trials remove
regulatory uncertainty for development
of new medical applications provide new
incentives for the development of drugs
for rare diseases help the entire
biomedical ecosystem to coordinate more
effectively to find cures faster and
invest
in 21st century science and
next-generation investigations the 21st
century cures act going on slide 10
passed the House of Representatives last
july july 10 2015 but the bill is
stalled in the Senate it really hasn't
gotten anywhere in the Senate this past
spring the Senate health education labor
and pensions committee reviewed and
passed a series of smaller biomedical
innovation fills that share the goal of
HR 6 which was the 21st century cures
act but they're a package of smaller
smaller bills not one all-encompassing
bill the health education labor and
pension committee chairmans levar Lamar
Alexander indicated that some of these
issues will be brought out of the
committee to be addressed in the Senate
floor later in this session but they
also want to include the oversight for
laboratory developed tests so let's talk
a little bit about congressional action
around the FDA proposed ldt regulation
so there's been significant debate over
the FDA's authority to regulate l DTS a
lot of stakeholders have written in to
the FDA to Congress to the to the
president about this this authority
Congress has showed a great deal of
interest so the House of Representatives
side the Energy and Commerce Committee
circulated a discussion draft bill in
October 2015 that keeps the maintains
the risk-based framework that the FDA
originally initiated for regulating in
vitro tests but creates new separate in
vitro center within the FDA with the
authority to regulate in vitro clinical
tests as a separate product under the
FD&C Act addition the Energy and
Commerce Committee held a hearing in
November of 2015
on the regulation of lab developed tests
were CMS centers for medicare medicaid
services and the fda both both testified
the appropriations committee included
report language that accompanied the the
fiscal year 2017 agricultural rural
development food and drug related
agencies funding bill and the funding
bill directed the fda to cease work on
its on its ldt guidance so you see two
different committees are taking somewhat
different approaches to this on the
house side and the senate side the
health education labor and pension
committee met with the association from
molecular pathology which is
professional association to discuss the
proposed modernized CLIA regulations the
clear regulations that are actually
administered by CMS are seen as a
possible alternative or different
approach to achieving the the risk-based
framework that was the FDA approved that
the FDA had proposed well not included
in bio medical innovations bill that was
marked up by the help committee LD TS
could be debated on the Senate floor as
I mentioned by the mar alexander so
think everybody's paying a lot of
attention to what might happen in this
next upcoming Senate session so looking
at some of the older expected
regulations that are traditionally
coming out over the course the next
several months talked about the payment
rules so going on to slide 15 for
anybody pays attention to you know all
these different payment rules this is
the normal course of events if you will
to update them the physician fee
schedule hospital inpatient hospital
outpatient clinical lab so on the
physician side the proposed rule is
expected in early July and this proposed
rule will actually be somewhat different
than past proposed rules in the past on
the Medicare physician fee schedule
new and revised CPT codes always came
out prices always came out in the final
rule this year for the first time new
and revised payment amounts will come
out in the proposed rule it actually
makes more sense that way because they
are being proposed and that due out in
early July usually around tomm July 4th
weekend the final rule then
traditionally is expected at the
beginning of november and those of
course will be implemented on january
first 2017 for the hospital outpatient
system and the inventory surgery center
system the proposed rule there is also
expected early July with the final rule
around November first implementation
there will also occur to life excuse me
january first 2017 the the overall theme
for the last several regulatory changes
in the hops payment system has been the
continuing packaging initiative of
comprehensive 8pcs and most observers
expect that that's going to continue in
this upcoming proposed and final rule as
well for the inpatient prospective
payment system the proposed rule was
just published April 2016 and the final
rule for the inpatient prospective
payment system is due out in August for
the clinical laboratory fee schedule
this is in advance of Pama which I'll be
talking about in a little bit but the
clinical laboratory fee schedule the
public meeting date has been set for the
whole process of crosswalk and gap-fill
for new clinical lab tests that date is
monday July eighteenth 2016 and CMS did
publish the list of neuse new laboratory
tests they're going to be priced through
that process the final pricing schedule
then is expected as it has traditionally
come in September prior to
implementation on january first 2017
moving on we're going to talk about the
pama Act
in the perfect am a proposed rule that
came out just in last year so brief
background catch everybody up to speed
on Pamela this is section 216 of Pama it
includes extensive reforms of the
clinical laboratory fee schedule these
reforms include a new reimbursement
framework that would base Medicare
payment rates for laboratory services
that are on the clinical lab fee
schedule on private payer rates that are
reported to CMS by applicable
laboratories so starting theoretically I
should say starting january first 2017
most rates on the clinical lab fee
schedule will be derived from private
payment amounts that are reported to and
tabulated by CMS for those laboratory
services designating certain tests as
the Pamela also designate certain tests
as advanced diagnostic laboratory tests
now go into that definition a little bit
but these advanced diagnostic laboratory
tests have different data collection
reporting and policies associated with
them that we'll be discussing pama also
has certain provisions that affect
coding and coverage and oversight of the
clinical laboratory fee schedule so the
the payment for the new advanced
diagnostic laboratory tests for any test
that is labeled as an ad LT are paid
using their actual list charge so the
the laboratory can for the first three
quarters on the clinical lab fee
schedule they can charge their their
list charge for the actual test the Ald
t-test after the initial period payment
is then based on the weighted median
private payer rates that are reported by
the laboratory to CMS for that new al DT
and then the fee is revised for the AL
DTS every year based on the median of
commercial payment rates for non Ald
newtek are still going to be paid based
on the group the crosswalk or gap fill
methodology until they are updated based
again on commercial median of commercial
payment rates 49 al DTS those tests will
be revised every three years instead of
every year as they are with al DTS so in
general the payment amount for a test on
the clinical lab fee schedule font
furnished on or after january first 2017
will be equal to the weighted median of
the private payer rates determined for
that test and but i think things are
shifting as we'll discuss here in a
moment and the implementation date is
likely to be pushed back so going on to
the next slide pema statute requires
final rulemaking to be completed by CMS
by june thirtieth 2015 well that didn't
happen CMS did not released the proposed
rule until the September 25th of 2015 so
they were behind schedule and then you
know going on they still not even
release the final rule yet so i think
the deadlines have definitely slipped
but let's talk a little bit about what
was in the proposed rule so there are
some changes that are a little different
than what most observers expected based
on the statutory language so CMS does
not expect hospital laboratories to meet
the definition of applicable laboratory
under the pama regulations so this is on
slide 20 CMS defines a laboratory as an
entity that is defined in regulations
under Clea so the clinical laboratory
Improvement Act is going to shape the
structure of what defined laboratory is
further all labs that are paid less than
50 thousand dollars a year based on
tests on the CL FS are excluded
from being an applicable laboratory and
thus from reporting private payer data
so they would not they would not have to
report the data under pama labs report
applicable information by taxpayer
identification number and only taxpayer
identification numbers receiving more
than fifty percent of the Medicare
revenues from either the clinical lab
fee schedule or the physician fee
schedule would be considered applicable
labs and so this would actually exempt
most hospital laboratories from meeting
this definition going on to the next
slide so these are some other proposed
definitions that CMS has put forth in
the proposed rule so this is a the Pema
statute in terms of defining what is in
advanced diagnostic laboratory tests the
payment a qu says what came out of
Congress says that al dt is laboratory
test that's covered under Medicare Part
B offered and marketed only by a single
laboratory not sold for use by
laboratory other than the originating
developing laboratory or successor owner
but it and it also needs to meet the
following criteria that the test is an
analysis of multiple biomarkers of DNA
RNA or proteins combined with a unique
algorithm to yield a single patient
specific result also that the test is
cleared or approved by the Food Drug
Administration the 10th or that the test
meets other similar criteria established
by the secretary so in the proposed rule
CMS changed this slightly so CMS is
proposing that an Ald T must be a
molecular pathology analysis of multiple
biomarkers of DNA or RNA they've
completely left off the
in component that was in in the pama
statute and they also say that it yields
a result that predicts the probability
an individual patient will develop a
certain condition or respond to a
particular therapy or therapies it also
provides new clinical diagnostic
information that cannot be obtained from
any other test or combination of tests
so as you can see here in the proposed
pama rule CMS is I would say pretty
significantly changing the definition of
an Ald t that has actually came out of
the pama statute so everybody is a
greatly anticipating what might come out
in the final rule in that regard pamela
also contains several coding provisions
for when new codes need to be developed
in the process for developing those
codes and who would control those codes
so some of which are that CMS must
assign a unique heck pics code for
existing al DTS and existing CLD teas
that are cleared or approved by the FDA
if they have not already been assigned a
unique Hickock's code to publicly report
the payment rate and again this is all
to uniquely identify it so you can
capture the the payment information
that's coming from commercial plans CMS
must assign temporary codes for certain
new advanced diagnostic lab tests or non
advanced diagnostic lab tests that are
cleared or approved by the FDA a lab or
manufacturer of a test kit may request a
unique identifier for an ald tea or a
test that's cleared or approved by the
FDA for purposes of tracking and
monitoring the laboratory services so in
the proposed rule CMS proposed the
creation of G codes to identify new and
existing advanced diagnostic lab tests
and
you CLD tease that are not al DTS but
those that are cleared by the FDA so I
think this is another area where there's
a lot of expectation about how CMS might
further develop the the coding process
in the final rule the AMA and the cpt
editorial panel have put forward their
own approach to this mckesson who
develops the Z codes have put forward to
approach as well and there's lots of
anticipation about what's going to
happen in the final rule to provide
these unique heck pics codes for al DTS
or for FDA cleared tests the timeline of
the rule which as I said is slipping so
the initial data collection period was
established by CMS to be from July first
2015 to December 31st 2015 the last two
quarters last year january first 2016
and then march through march 31st 2016
reports were submitted to CMS for
determining 2017 clinical labs fee
schedule payment rates and CMS developed
a an infrastructure to allow them to
collect that and the annual laboratory
public meeting for new tests does occur
in July it's as I mentioned before it's
gonna be July 2016 and CMS is still
going to use that meeting for cross
walking or gap filling rates that are
not advanced diagnostic laboratory tests
as I mentioned if you're in a ldt you do
have the ability to send your own
payment rate for the first three
quarters September 2016 CMS publishes
the preliminary rates for either gap
towed across walked and then November
2016 CMS will publish the final SI lfs
rates for the calendar year 2017 and
then those rates then become effective
on Jan
first there is a significant delay in
the proposed rule that's going to create
a tricky schedule for CMS for the data
collection period which is which is
actually at this point going to set to
begin before the release of the proposed
rule so there's lots of unanswered
questions this delay coupled with
scheduling constraints and several other
concerns not the least of which are all
the coding issues that are unresolved as
well as the definition of an Ald t has
many stakeholders calling for delay and
members of Congress have also written
into CMS asking for delay in the pimp
limitation of Pama so that that remains
to be seen what's going to occur there
moving on to slide 24 we're going to
talk about macra which is stands for the
Medicare access and chip reauthorization
Act and this is a proposed rule that
we're going to be talking about that
does CMS came out with about a month ago
a month and a half ago to talk about how
they're going to implement the the macro
reg and this is the changes to physician
payment and this this is a pretty
complicated slide but the gist of which
I think can largely be largely be gained
if you look at the graph in the within
that dotted box so the benefit of the
macro legislation was that it repealed
the old SGR formula and the sustainable
growth rate formula which every year
competi compression factor on the
Medicare physician fee schedule and the
solid red line represents what that
baseline would be and you can see there
that it's a pretty dramatic dip if if
Congress had not intervened in past
Macra physician fees on the whole would
have went down considerably to the base
from the baseline went down by more than
twenty percent and then what it kind of
slowly crept back up after that
initial initial hit over the first two
years but as a result of macra and some
of the changes that macro is putting
forward such as the the MIPS plan and
the alternative payment model plan will
allow physicians to recoup actually get
additional payment from medicare by
either perdis participating in a an
alternative payment model or to submit
performance measures and quality
guidelines to CMS and so you can see
there at the highest level under MIPS a
physician the highest performing level
exceptional physicians would be in store
for a pretty pretty handsome bonus if if
again just for the exceptional
performing physicians and this is you
know this is in theory if you meet all
the requirements so beginning july first
july 2015 through 2019 macro is going to
adjust the existing conversion factor by
0.5% but then beginning in 2020 it's
going to be flat so 2020 through 2025
the conversion factor will be flat 26
and beyond it's going to creep up a
little bit you get a quarter percent
boost unless you're participating in an
alternative payment model and then
you'll be eligible for an additional
0.5% so a three quarter of a percent
whose but it does establish the new
physician incentive payment programs
would we're going to be talking about
here in a little bit and that the
proposed rule recently came out on so
the next slide slide 26 is a timeline
that talks about how this is going to be
implemented over time so over time the
incentives for physicians to control
costs increase 2017 marks the
transitions to physicians being held
more explicitly accountable for
controlling beneficiary overall care
costs 2016 is the last year that
can participate in the the kind of
existing physician quality reporting
system value-based modifier system 2017
is a transition year for the first
performance year for the new MIPS or
APM's payment with incentives penalties
still reflect performance based on the
old PQRS or value-based modifier
measures not all physicians will will be
participating in the value-based
modifier component until 2018 because
that did not affect all practices
beginning 2019 and moving forward the
mayor based incentive payment system
which is the MIPS and the alternative
payment model will kick in and there'll
be penalties / incentives to affect
providers participating in those
approaches payment approaches beginning
in 2019 so going on to tab or slide 27
implementation of these programs is
expected to further CMS's efforts to
move away from a fee-for-service payment
system and to pay begin to pay for value
that as we all know the devil is in the
details here so initially as I mentioned
it's going to consolidate the
value-based modifier PQRS electronic
health records meaningful use is going
to stabilize physician reimbursement
it's going to create these new
incentives pathways so this talk a
little bit in the next slide about the
timeline to macro implementation and
this is both this is from the proposed
rule on macro as well as what was in the
statute obviously so the fee updates you
see on the top line there and you can
see what's going to happen with the
overall fee schedule updates how it's
going to increase a little bit taper off
to nothing
and then in beginning 2019 the MIPS and
alternative payment models begin the
mayor base incentive payment program for
doctors treating Medicare beneficiaries
will doctors will have to participate in
either of these paths either the
alternative payment model where they
would participate in in an ACO type plan
accountable care organization type plan
where there is some sort of risk share
and CMS does go on to talk about risk
share and we'll just that little bit in
a moment where physicians need to
participate in the mayor based incentive
payment system and other under the mayor
basement incentive payment system you
can see here that they've over the years
they have different rates of either
bonuses or penalties depending on the
extent to which they are able to meet
the merit incentive payments so the
those incentive payments in this small
pie chart here are broken down fifteen
percent our clinical practice
improvement activities thirty percent of
the the incentive payments of them the
merits are based on quality of care
thirty percent on resource use and then
twenty five percent is is going back to
kind of the old Meaningful Use measure
for electronic health records going on
to slide 29 so drilling into MIPS a
little bit more in some of those
categories under MIPS you can see that
the the amount the distribution of those
changes slightly over the over the years
but the the performance category waits
for 20 19 20 20 and 21 plus begins in
nineteen with a greater emphasis on
quality slightly less emphasis on
resource use moving on to decreasing
emphasis on quality increasing emphasis
on
resource use to the point at which in
2020-21 forward resource use emphasis is
at thirty percent quality down to thirty
percent advanced care information at
twenty-five percent in clinical practice
improvement activities fifteen percent
so you can see a is you could say away
from quality to emphasis on resource use
this is of concern to many particularly
in the provider community obviously
going on to slide 30 this again is
looking at a time line but the intention
here is to show that all the different
pieces that need to fall into place for
successful implementation of Macra and
so far CMS seems to be on target with
the deadlines but for 2016 the
integration has Medicaid claims data
into physicians so that they can compare
the comments are due to CMS on the draft
plan for major development that's March
30 march first that occurred April
sixteenth the secretary of health and
human services needs to clarify how
consumers are protected May first final
major development plans due from CMS and
so far these have all been achieved
study to Congress from HHS on the
integration of the alternative payment
models into Medicare Advantage plans and
then November first the criteria for a
PMS the alternative payment models
advisory panel do from HHS and the final
list of initial MIPS measures quality
measures are due from CMS so we'll see
if they continue to meet these so early
indications are that the MIPS final rule
is it's possible that it could be
delayed beyond November which might
delay implementation of the myths and
the AP
m's the final as I mentioned the final
rules out excuse me the proposed rules
out comments were due on that and CMS
right now is deliberating on those
comments and I suspect getting lots of
visits from from physician specialty
societies moving on to slide 31 so we're
going to talk a little bit about
defining cost quality measurement for
physician payment the current quality
measures are primarily focused on
process where there's appropriate
assessment management of chronic
conditions appropriate screening of
preventive care and the idea here under
MIPS is they want to develop additional
cost measures primarily focus on
episodes of care and total per capita
costs so there's going to be Medicare
spending per beneficiary total per
capita cost for Medicare beneficiaries
and total per capita cost for benefits
beneficiaries with specific conditions
in CMS is developing episode groupers to
help enable this data collection so that
as I mentioned the measures right now
are primarily process driven but CMS
requires that clinicians report at least
one outcome measure and one cross
cutting measure for a total of only six
quality measures so this is going to be
I think a real challenge for a lot of
clinicians to be able to achieve what
they need to achieve talking a little
bit about the episode Gruber's on the
next slide there's are intended to hold
specialty providers accountable for cost
so CMS has proposed the use of episode
Gruber's in the in resource use
measurement each episode is defined by a
triggering event or diagnosis rather
than including all the costs occurred
during a specific time period the egm is
is going to include agric
it's of services and associated costs
identified as clinically relevant to the
triggering event in the cost calculation
the episode groups were proposed by CMS
for 41 clinical conditions for example
cardiovascular GI rest respiratory
conditions expectations for physicians
under the MIPS program versus the APM
and in terms of who is expected now
which physicians are expected to
participate which model the AMA and
others has American Medical Association
other physician groups have exerted
significant pressure on CMS to include
one side risk accountable care
organizations as a TMS CMS has pushed
back and CMS has proposed inclusion of
only two sided risk apms to served as
the advanced apms through which
clinicians could avoid the MIPS penalty
you know which which means that you know
you have to participate in either a PMS
or MIPS if you're in a single sided APM
then you need to participate in MIPS and
there you would be penalized than if you
do not is the idea here it's somewhat
more strict than the AMA and the
physicians want at this point and I
think we're going to have to see how
that plays out in the final rule by
excluding ACOs and steering apm's toward
models with true downside risk it leaves
the majority of physicians who will
likely be participating in a PM there
excuse me in the MIPS program until
there are more qualifying apms that can
be developed so again what to see how
this this plays out but excluding one
side risk ACOs would ultimately create
stronger incentives for physicians to
pursue improve tossed quality or
outcomes so again CMS
going on to the next slide CMS has set a
high bar for a PMS to qualify as
advanced ATMs to avoid a mips you need
to participate in the advanced a PMS so
clinician must take on a marginal risk
rate of at least thirty percent take on
a total potential risk of at least four
percent of expected expenditures and
record over twenty-five percent of
Medicare revenue through the advanced
APM as a result of these you know
there's pretty high bar that's expect
the majority of physicians will
participate MIPS since the advanced
apm's are not fully developed only there
are only five existing apm's that meet
CMS's criteria there are a few options
for specialty providers to participate
in these advanced ATMs so CMS estimates
that in excess of 600,000 to accept
almost 750 eligible clinicians would
fall under MIPS the MIPS requirements
and 4 2016 only 30,000 90,000 eligible
clinicians would be able to avoid MIPS
by participating in advanced 8pm as I
mentioned there are only five existing
apm's that are considered advanced so
the existing advanced ATMs are the next
generation acos that were established in
Riggs several months ago at this point
last year so the oncology care models a
two-sided risk comprehensive primary
care plus comprehensive end-stage renal
disease care and the MSSP track to and
track three Affordable Care accountable
care organizations the ones that are not
considered advanced ATMs are the Part B
drug payment model which was just
delayed by CMS the one side of risk ACOs
and Medicare
vonage plans as well as the oncology
care model that's all that's based on
one side of risk so CMS is really
pushing hard for two-sided risk in the
advanced EPS so if you haven't got the
idea yet the advanced alternative
payment models are an area of key
stakeholder interest CMS is taking a
variety of input from healthcare payment
and learning and Action Network the core
quality measures collaborative that
they've set up and the physician pockets
focused payment model Technical Advisory
Committee that they've also set up to
help inform their decision-making on
this the health care payment learning
and Action Network CMS has convened
private payers other stakeholders to
provide recommendations on implementing
pay for value to understand what are the
best practices for patient attribution
best practices financial benchmarking
frameworks for population-based payment
models and that all kind of comes
together the recommendations will be
incorporated into CMS's model through
rulemaking and commercial payment models
through contracting the quarter quality
major collaborative that was recently
established by CMS in America's Health a
hip America's Health Information plans
when the chief medical officers convene
leaders from CMS as well as a hip in the
National Quality forum and national
physician groups as well and the idea
here is to develop core quality major
collaborative to identify several core
measure sets that contain standardized
quality metrics for use across private
payer programs so they're trying to to
come up with key measurement sets in in
several high impact areas such as
cardiology gastroenterology
HIV have been tied to see medical
oncology obstetrics orthopaedics the
measurement sets are intended to inform
the payment models and ultimately CMS
and private payers have agreed to
incorporate these into the measurement
sets for quality reporting and the pay
for value program moving on helping
Human Services has established a
physician focused payment model
Technical Advisory Committee PTAC and
the p-tech is charged with defining
criteria for physician focused payment
reviews models that are submitted and
provide recommendations to the secretary
of HHS as to whether the model should be
implemented thus far the p-tech has
requested comments on a process for
submission of physician focused payment
models what the statutory requirements
are to define the criteria and the
meetings are going to the meeting the
meetings will be held public as a way of
seeking additional broader clinical
input the American Medical Association
hopes to use the p-tech and if to
pressure the agency to loosen its
interpretation of the advance
alternative payment models however the
chair of the p-tech has stated that it's
unclear whether the pan will be allowed
to act in such a role because after all
it is still controlled by the secretary
so moving on to slide 41 the expected
regulations they as I mentioned
throughout several regulations have been
delayed pama the final rule is expected
any moment now and it's and greatly
anticipated to clarify some of these
issues with respect to advanced
diagnostic lab tests as well as coding
final FDA guidance I know DT regulation
is also expected that's been TV
d for quite a while now the thinking is
part of many observers that since
Congress has expressed some interest FDA
has postponed that but both pama final
roll and FDA guidance on ldt regulations
will have significant impact on the
laboratory industry other executive
activities there's some administrative
initiatives that might have a downstream
impact on clinical labs there's the
precision medicine initiative that came
out of the executive branch established
the public public-private partnership
was launched early last year the aim is
to leverage advances in genomics
informatics health information
technology to accelerate bio medical
discoveries in the hopes of yielding
more personalized medical treatments for
patients and president obama signed into
law budget agreement that earmarked 200
million specifically for the precision
medicine initiative then februari of
this year the White House how the
precision medicine medicine summit where
the administration announced key actions
to accelerate provision prove precision
medicine pardon me also as you know late
last year the vice president announced
the cancer moonshot it's his intention
to spend his remaining time in office
working on an effort to cure cancer
January 2016 the State of the Union
address President Obama announced the
new national effort to cure cancer that
is to be led by Vice President Biden
President Obama established the White
House cancer moonshot task force and
Biden is going to host a national cancer
moonshot summit on jun 29th this year so
that's the viewpoint from Washington DC
I'd be happy to answer any questions I
know it was a little long winded and
pretty technical particularly around
Macra one-sided risk
cited risk MIPS etc but they have been
answer any questions excellent
presentation mr. Beebe thanks for
bringing that information to us so
before we get started with all of your
questions here's a quick reminder about
how to reach us today questions can be
sent via the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
get to as many as we can while we're
waiting for questions do you have any
final comments um I do not have any
final comments at this time just just to
remind you that I still do not have
internet connectivity so if you would
read the questions for me you'll be
greatly appreciated mark store will give
the audience a moment to to submit their
questions
okay well i would like to once again
thank Michael D D for his presentation
here's there there are no questions
today I also like to thank our sponsor
Cardinal Health for making it possible
to bring this presentation to you this
is an educational webinar and thus
offers free continuing education credits
after the webinar is over and to get
your credit to click on the button
located on the bottom left hand corner
of your web page today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
September's forgive 2016 you'll receive
an email from us alerting you when it's
available on demand and posted on
larousse calm you are welcome to forward
this announcement to any colleagues who
weren't able to join in today thanks for
logging on and participating in today's
broadcast and don't miss the next
webinar inspectors at your door is your
QC ready presented by therese wallach
and sponsored by bio-rad hope to see you
there at two p.m. eastern time take
thank you take care